you got the hit TV show that would be
enough for most Silicon Valley one of my
favorite television shows hilarious then
you get the Oscar nomination 2017 has
been an incredible year for you yeah
it's been I would say 2017 has been a
global disaster and a personal triumph
change a thing 2017 it's been tough I'm
like yeah I made a movie and then I got
known for an Oscar it's really not a big
deal yeah I wish you wouldn't bring it
up all the time
yeah plan on being insufferable yeah yes
yeah I've been a dick for so long and
now I have a reason yeah I'm going to
I'm going to Starbucks and they were
like they're like what's your name I'm
like I'm Oscar nominee Kumail please
he's very awkward because Daniel
day-lewis was there - three-time Oscar
winner Daniel day-lewis yeah yeah I hate
it when I go to the same coffee shop
it's an are you you know this has got to
be changing your life I mean you were
getting recognized before you're on a
hit show but now you got to be getting
recognized a lot more yeah I was I was
at another coffee shop and I was just
sitting there drinking my coffee and
this person came up to me and she was
very shy and she's like hey I was like
hey and she's like I don't normally do
this but you're so talented what you do
mean so much to me I love you on Big
Bang Theory and that's just how famous I
am people think I'm in shows I'm not
even in
Oh what do you do in that situation ILM
I'm not Mayim Bialik I always say the
same line I always go that's the other
one this is your awkwardness I don't
have to deal with this right right I
used to be like hot I'm sorry but now
I'm like yeah that's a different one I
wish I was done Big Bang Theory yeah but
in this era of political you know
correctness and people wanting to say
the right thing those people must feel
terrible in that moment I feel awful I
was at the Critics Choice Awards a
couple of weeks ago and I won't say who
but a very famous person came up to me
and it was like hey and I'm like hey I'm
so excited to meet you and they're like
oh ya know we know each other from Big
Bang Theory oh my god this was a really
famous person it was a very famous
person who's done small parts on that
show and I kept thinking I thinking
there's no way you can come up with this
that was the night our movie won best
comedy and I was like what is it gonna
take I get you're great on the daily
show I mean this happens to me all the
time another thing I say is or one of
the major closes that we have completely
different faces yeah
[Laughter]
you